en fait la politique des banques
centrales elle a provoqué une forme de
croyance chez les investisseurs que
leurs investissements désormais aider
complètement garanti c'est l'une des
raisons qui expliquent les performances
tout à fait étincelante des bourses
durant l'année qui vient de s'écouler
non c'est un comportement malsain et ça
on est tous allés à le constater et à le
déplorer et c'est ce qui explique
évidemment la volonté des banques
centrales de changer de politique
de la fed américaine à la bce en passant
par la banque d'angleterre l'heure est
au serrage de vis après des années de
largesses les grands banque centrale
entame la normalisation des politiques
monétaires notamment aux états unis mais
comment agir sur les vannes du crédit
sont peser sur une croissance qui
s'essouffle déjà c'est le dilemme des
banques centrales et on en parle tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
seller dit aux échos
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france encore un petit peu
à distance la semaine prochaine on aura
le plaisir de vous avoir à nouveau en
plateau jacques après donc cessé et non
au sein de ces derniers jours où va-t-on
vers la fin de de l'argent facile celui
des versets notamment par les banques
centrales
oui c'est fini il est clair qu'on va
assister à un changement assez profond
des politiques des banques centrales la
réserve fédérale américaine par exemple
a été appliquée il faut s'attendre
désormais à trois voire quatre
resserrement des taux pour 2022 et
surtout la baisse de ce que l'on appelle
le bilan de l'établissement pour la
vente des titres qui ont été achetés en
masse depuis deux ans en fait il faut
toujours rappeler que depuis le début de
la crise monétaire la taille du bilan de
la fed a doublé alors la bce quand elle
l est plus prudente les achats de titres
liés à la pandémie vont néanmoins se
réduire progressivement au premier
semestre et christine lagarde a été
quand même plus évasif sur la
perspective de hausses de taux les
banques centrales doivent naviguer vous
l'avait dit entre la crainte que la
hausse de l'inflation ne s'accélère et
le fait que l'ex perspectives de la
croissance dans de nombreux pays de
l'union européenne eh bien elles ont été
révisées à la baisse est tout d'abord
jacques où en est on des des engagements
de ces banques
alors stéphanie ses engagements ils
peuvent être suivis tout simplement par
l'évolution des dettes alors celle des
ménages celle des entreprises non
financières est aussi celle des états
l'ont l'endettement des agents vie non
financiers privés autrement dit les
ménages et les entreprises a augmenté de
manière très significative durant la
crise sanitaire c'est le résultat
justement des politiques de soutien qui
ont été mises en place par les
différentes banques centrales ces
dernières ont racheté des titres de
dette pas seulement ceux des états nous
toujours l'indiqué mais aussi ceux des
entreprises ces rachats par ailleurs ils
ont été plus ou moins importants suivant
les pays si vous prenez par exemple les
états unis et l'allemagne est bien le
mouvement d'endettement des entreprises
durant la pandémie a été relativement
faible par contre si vous prenez le cas
japon de la france du royaume uni et
bien là on voit que le mouvement il a
été nettement plus élevé les bilans des
banques centrales donc très lourdement
chargés de titres d'entreprises mais
aussi évidemment d'obligations publiques
comme vous l'avez souligné hal et des
publics ont aussi largement augmenté
mais normalement c'est d'être n'aurait
pas at elle pas dû se retrouver dans
dans les comptes des banques centrales
effectivement c'est fini mais il ya
quand même pas mal de marge entre la
théorie et la pratique on fait même la
banque centrale européenne à racheter
des obligations d'état alors bien sûr
elle disait pas à racheter directement
au gouvernement sur ce qu'on appelle le
marché primaire mais les arracher au
banc de plus à travers le pe pp le
fameux fonds d'urgence créé pour lutter
contre la pandémie et bien la bce a pu
racheter directement des obligations
d'état ceci a aussi été rendu possible
par la baisse des taux ainsi même si le
taux à 10 ans sur les obligations
publiques françaises est redevenu
positif une coût de l'endettement
globalement est toujours très faible et
tout cela ne va pas durer
naturellement non c'est naturellement
dont les pressions pour que les banques
centrales reviennent à des politiques
plus restrictives
celle d'avant la crise par exemple se
multiplient on peut le comprendre la
hausse de l'inflation et de 7% aux
etats-unis de 5 4% en allemagne bref une
partie de l'opinion publique qui réclame
désormais des politiques plus respirer
plus restrictive mais ce n'est pas la
seule raison en fait la politique des
banques centrales elle a provoqué une
forme de croyance chez les investisseurs
que leurs investissements désormais
aider complètement garanti c'est une des
raisons qui expliquent les performances
tout à fait et insolente des bourses
durant l'année qui vient de s'écouler
alors c'est un comportement malsain
hasard mais tout ça le à le constater et
à le déplorer et c'est ce qui explique
évidemment la volonté des banques
centrales de changer de politique et la
question est que vont elles faire
alors elles peuvent utiliser et elles
vont utiliser en réalité deux
instruments le premier va être de ces
c'est justement d'acheter ces titres
voire de revendre une partie des titres
qu'elles détiennent pour faire dégonfler
leur bilan le second va consister en des
hausses régulières des taux
d'intervention ce qu'on appelle
classiquement les taux directeurs alors
si on prend le cas de la réserve
fédérale cette dernière a annoncé un
dégonflement rapide de son bilan et la
perspective d'au moins trois housses de
taux pour 2022 est cependant pas du tout
impossible que la pression monte sur la
réserve fédérale et qu'elle procède en
réalité à quatre hausses de taux cette
année la bce quant à elle prévoit un
arrêt du programme d'urgence ne va me
payer bp au premier trimestre de 2022
mais devant l'importance de l'inflation
en allemagne et devant la réaction
évidemment d'une partie de l'opinion
publique allemande face à cette
inflation est bien il est probable
qu'elle sera malgré tout obligé
d'accélérer ces mesures restrictives et
tout ceci aura évidemment des
conséquences vac
oui oui évidemment c'est à dire compte
tenu du niveau d'endettement de tous les
agents les entreprises les ménages ou si
l'état les banques centrales sont
condamnés à être très prudents si elles
agissent trop fort ou trop brutalement
elle risque de provoquer une montée de
l'insolvabilité des agents non
financiers ont mieux de compromettre la
croissance
s'ils agissent trop faiblement leurs
actions risquent de ne pas avoir le
poids nécessaire pour modifier justement
les comportements la marche d'action et
donc et 3 mais ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que les pressions des politiques
et d'une partie de l'opinion publique
pour que les banques centrales
resserrent le crédit vont être appelés à
monter au moins dans le premier semestre
de l'année 2022 de quoi sera faite cette
année 2022 dans le domaine monétaire
il est clair stéphanie que nous aurons
un changement de politique de la part
des banques centrales avec une hausse
générale des taux mais la vraie question
c'est est-ce que les banques centrales
seront elles libres d'agir comme elle le
souhaitait donc de maintenir quand même
une certaine prudence ou bien trouveront
thème se plier à des pressions
politiques d'autre part dans quelle
mesure l'économie mondiale
réagira-t-elle à des politiques
monétaires qui vont s'avérer être très
divergents ça va y avoir déjà une
divergence entre la politique monétaire
aux états unis et la politique monétaire
dans l'union politique monétaire de la
bce mais il a aussi y avoir une
divergence importante entre les
etats-unis et la chine où la banque
centrale vient quant à elle de baisser
son taux directeur ce qui est
complètement à contre courant de ce qui
est fait ailleurs c'est ce type de
divergence vab évidemment impliquée une
très grande volatilité des taux de
change merci jacques pour ses mises en
garde et à la semaine prochaine pour un
nouvel édito merci à vous